Look,
we we,
we are still hopeful that President
Obama will make,
will keep the promises he made his
candidate,
but there was some early signs that
we're not going down the right path.
He told us we would reject the military
commissions act,
and yet now he's talking about retaining
the military commissions as a way to
deal with some of the detainees at
Guantanamo.
Huge mistake,
you can't fix that.
You got scrap.
It got throw these individuals and to
establish courts,
you can't tinker at the edges with the
Military Commissions Act.
He told us he would restore the rule of
law and yet now he's telling us that he
wants to elect a preventive detention
regime,
which is essentially a nice word for
holding people indefinitely without
charge or trial.
Can't do that.
That's not the American way.
We've never allowed that for hundreds of
years.
America cannot hold people who we are
suspicious of merely because they may
pose a threat.
If you can't prove it,
you can't take away someone's
fundamental right to liberty and do so
in a way that doesn't a convict the
person in a court of law that's just,
it's anathema to the fourth and fifth
amendments.
You have the president telling us that
he was going to make good on some core
issues around gay rights and questions
around equality in America.
That seemed to be very slow in coming.
Uh,
you know,
saying that I'm going to give gay,
lesbian people.
They're full rights as individuals and
yet defending the defensive marriage
act.
It doesn't compute,
frankly,
if,
if those promises were made,
you can't defend the defense of marriage
act.
You can't drag your feet.
Don't ask,
don't tell.
And I think one of the concerns we have
is that the president is saying,
I have all these other issues that are
on the front burner,
the economy,
the wars,
healthcare.
We all get that.
We're all Americans.
We all care about people dying in wars.
We all care about health care,
we all care about the economy,
but frankly we can't wait to fix all
those problems before we get to some
really important problems.
Uh,
he,
he and he alone in his garment
conflicts.
You can't sequence in a way that's going
to.
You got to fix the economy,
the healthcare and the environment and
the wars,
and then we'll turn to gay people and
the administration of Justice and
detainees and torture and abuse.
It's not,
we're not,
we're never going to get to.
And frankly everyone knows that it's the
first 18 months of an administration
that will allow him the room and the
latitude to make decisive breaks with
the past.
And unless we,
we occupied that initial window with
some really bold,
decisive actions,
we'll find ourselves in a new reelection
campaign.
We'll find ourselves with pundits on
both sides saying differ these issues
further until the second term.
And frankly a dream deferred is a dream
last.
And frankly a time is not a luxury we
can afford ourselves when it comes to
core issues like due process and human
rights and equality.
And that's why we're hoping by putting
his feet to the fire and these issues
that who get the political will to do
the right thing.